what is going on there reject nation we are going
to watch today the boys season 3 finale i am so
excited to see how this season wraps up it has
been stellar stellar maybe we'll rank it after
we're done reacting to it but guys please leave a
like that helps us out on the algorithm very much
so also subscribe and click that notification
bell to get notified when uh reaction or some
other video is up here on the channel that peaks
your interest full length watch along where you
sync up with a time code meaning use your own copy
for the boys or over at our patreon page i want to
thank each and every one of you who has supported
us by becoming a super sexy reject by joining our
patreon page we cover a bunch of shows over there
we're at the same tier you get the option for
reaction highlights and watch alongs included
the prepper team thank you so much for helping
us edit down these highlights over the weeks and
also want to give a mention that any of our like
commentary review tracks all those get uploaded
to our podcast which you can find the real rejects
over at apple spotify anywhere where podcasts
are found and lastly thank you to storyblocks for
sponsoring us for each one of these boys reactions
you have saved us in times of age restriction
videos and yellow dollar bill signs there's been
plentiful when it comes to the boys so thank
you guys for uh supporting us throughout this
journey anywho let's see how this all wraps up
oh i knew your fastball would come in sooner or
later oh [__] stay away from him okay i'm not
here to cause trouble just want to see my son and
i had a heck of a time trying to find you buddy i
even had to get a big important congresswoman
to help me oh my god damn you have a real
family aren't you mad at me oh no for
what i did when you're as strong as
we are accidents happen but but that's all it is
an accident and nobody on this earth knows that
better than me oh you're a good homelander
that's why i'm always going to love you
i'm not going anywhere i will always be here
yikes damn it yikes
god's guns and homelander
and she's on her way here
right now with a search warrant to look for her
what are they gonna move her
please tell me they're just gonna move her
come on maeve break out of there superhero
breakout a lot worse damn not for those guys
homelanders shocking admissions on starlight's
instagram live feed led to the largest single
day drop in the history of vaught like i was
scared there deep and i had to move maeve out
of the tower you were there you were there
rolling with back up so worried black noir is
going to die where is maeve now you are hey
bro we're just gonna we're gonna go
oh he can't even spell soldier properly you really
are i spin the image of my little brother what
he'll never get out you've only ever been
about yourself i'm sorry i'll make it right
how every time you try you make it worse
ouch i said get the [__] out of my house
i don't want to murder her in the same
house with my kid god damn it don't touch me
don't come back here how
could he ever make it right
goddamn somebody walking away at this point
did he tell you tell me what that tempy is
fatal if you shot up anymore you'd probably
be dead right now that [__] saved my life
she stopped me from taking more v in his own
messed up way i spent so much time thinking he was
a loser you know what dad was there taking care of
me during during the worst days of his life just
trying to keep the lights on and a roof above
our heads wow finally appreciate him he wasn't
weak i just i didn't know what strength was oh
i i never should have put any of this onto you
thank you for saying that but go [__] yourself
hey maeve good to see you again glad you're okay
it's like you wear a neon sign that says raw dog
me i'm a bottle i'm gonna let you two catch up
no shame and bottom and huey yeah nina was right
my papa i put a chain around my neck and all
that [__] changes is who holds the other end
oh what do you see
there are a couple thousand
people in that building
i mean if he pulls a hirogasm he's going
to take the whole [__] place down
we take down soulja boy before he gets to
homeland they wouldn't have an orgy there
they probably got a whole floor for orgies
i went to boarding school got kicked out of
boarding school because i was a fuck-up and
he made sure i knew it he was a belt did he
never laid a hand on me he couldn't be bothered
oh and they got me into dr vox compound v trials
i became a superhero strongest man alive
[__] ticker tape parades when i came home
and what did the old man sight in he said
i took a shortcut oh god of course he did
ugh i'm linda right yours he's the only blood
i've got left it doesn't matter you didn't name
him didn't raise him he's a [__] reason they
left you to roll with the ivins we had a deal
i would have hammered home the the
point you were already making first
move him there yeah you were in his team
you knew him what was he like he always wanted his
father i was wondering come on nobody's all bad
he's my father wow wowie i ripped apart
the company archives and it's true
it's true oh god now
did you
who never had know
father out there oh no don't alive this
whole time oh god damn it black no hard
oh [__] oh no no no
damn it what did you tell me god dammit
no oh
god you're the only one of
the seven i'm sad to see die
dammit watch him live through this
so worried that was gonna happen
we are so proud of you soon you'll be in the
sweet embrace of kkk christ the lord oh jesus
oh show us jesus so worried that was going to
happen second he showed back up in this episode
[__] me she was dead hey you didn't think i
knew where the blind spots were [__] back up
oh god soldier boy goes through with this
thousands will die becca worked in the tower
you shut your [__] keiko frenchie
no you will never commend me again i am done
with your cruelty okay i deserve respect and
we all deserve paid vacation days and again
go frenchy and a 401k unionized friendship
butcher's right homelander needs
to die that's it whatever it takes
i don't want to hurt you but
i will oh oh god oh no oh god
think about i don't trust soldier boy nope not
an inch we ran it through the voice thingamabob
it's really her so you know i think we should
probably evacuate nobody's evacuating anything
we have to project strength right no that's
smart strength are you pathetic loser
such excellent delivery you know
when the company first rolled me
out in front of the cameras they told
me i was gonna get my very own team
i wanted so badly for that team to be the family
that i never got and then i got you oh my god
ashley take off that brick
what wig oh oh no ashley no
oh she's pulled her hair out so
much hasn't oh ashley yes wowie
if dakota bob taps me for vp i'd be honored
off the record i'm expecting
good news at the prayer breakfast
homelander's so mean he's my role model
deep do that that's my guess
it's like the movie species there is one lab in
new york that might be stoked with the things i
need and this fate would have it we are headed
there so you're joking we're gonna break in the
vault yes and you're gonna cook up the world's
most dangerous neurotoxin with what little
moxie and the little mr wizard know-how
while we hold off homelander and soulja boy
the most important [__] of my life
and i'm counting on coked out euro trash
hey be nice to frenchy he he
grew as a character just now
no
oh come on i bring it okay
yeah you never know
where's noir i killed him because he didn't tell
me about you i know what it's like to have your
team betray you but with you and i together
they wouldn't stand a chance nobody would
family business get ryan in on it too
he ain't your kid yes i am i am your son
i am your blood that's all that matters
god damn maybe oh god i'm so on it
ugh this is your grandson ryan
this is my son ryan your grandson no
[__] god damn it no not the g word
you're a family you have him
and you have me oh you're so
clever the shame that i've missed
so much i wish i could have raised you oh
maybe if i'd raised you
i could have made you better oh
my god oh no weak sniveling [__]
becoming your dad but there's
no fixing that her smile
oh my god wow get out of building now
get back upstairs right now
this is the worst case scenario
not with the kid there though
brian
ah crap
no crap
oh man this is so bad no i can't
believe this is happening my two dads
i did not see this coming at all not the kid i
thought you said blood didn't matter but that
was a whole [__] point he's my wife's son
everything you wanted he's right [__] there
and now you blink stand down
[__] you you're weaker than he is
god damn it homelander help
him fight would you yeah
hey [__]
not now maeve we have bigger fish i don't
yeah i've been said not now
come on maeve god damn maeve are you trying to get
yourself killed get a few good licks in at least
there we go there we go there has been a
terrorist threat called into the building
please leave as quickly as you can this is not
a drill this is not a test where are you going
ashley with you ashley to the helipad yeah so the
sikorsky is actually reserved for svps and higher
wow sorry ashley leave as
quickly as you can oh it's fine
i'll just sprint to the bottom of this
high-ass tower homelander you you evil genius
nice work nice work oh damn
god damn it's nice to get a good fight yeah
my own blood
one eye patch it'll be okay
oh god
i don't know why you've never seen them hotter
than now yeah man it's that unbridled fury
oh my god
a little excessive but yeah sure why not you
know there's more need to release more people no
no no
nice
oh you broke his shield
god damn it that hurts
oh no no
oh no no no no no no no no no oh
he's gonna be up it's the only way
oh my god is this gonna happen
think faster huey
oh charger up nice
star god ah sargasm
that's called supporting your woman no no
just gets right back up son of a [__]
you ain't no hero you're just another racist piece
of [__] we can't seem to get
rid of this is one of my family
god damn
no
oh no no
oh [__]
oh my god ah she did it
oh maeve both black noir and maeve holy [__]
here we go again i want to go let's leave
please wow what a reversal from last season
please
how long ago months 12 18 on the
outside you can kind of [__] off then
it's me
are you
there yes
you look like [__] [__] off smurfette soldier
boys alive somewhere should i get a pirate patch
or the sammy davis glass eye
oh the pirate patch no question
yeah you ready hey oh my god she came back
dang where will you guys go i know somewhere
homelander won't find me into a bunker
you're like a walking homework hard enough
bye oh bye maeve and then homelanders
just right outside the doors
god damn it ashleys
yes yes finally grew one spinal column
don't worry someone will
thaw him out at some point
go cassandra i don't need it
i don't the suit never gave me any power and
thought sure [__] didn't definitely should
have burnt it we're in a historic building you
need to double knot okay and bag your trash
if you're gonna be working here butcher
isn't gonna like it bucha can suck my [__]
after the tragic drowning of presumptive
vp candidate lamar bishop we go live to the
singer campaign in sioux falls where dakota
bob just announced his new running mate
what would you like to say to
the american people oh christ
yes as the next vice president i will work hard to
provide a safe and secure future for all citizens
i am so proud to have her on my team
we're going after the white house
that [__] is definitely gonna go
[__] you and your eyes
coming to be with these people yep yep hi good
to see you i love you guys you are america true
patriots hey do you want to meet someone someone
very special to me oh christ you're not no role
model no are you really oh you're sick son of
a [__] this little guy here is my son ryan
god your points are gonna be through the roof
wow what's up todd
they're gonna cheer aren't they yup
oh no no no no
oh great
no
wow
that is cruel and twisted that makes sense
that's the way it would go yeah well [__] i feel
like they got like two more seasons left in them
one or two at least um that was great that
was an amazing finale yeah [__] that was
i'm in a daze it's shocking that was a lot of
shocking shocking stuff in there man there's
a crescendo oh man what's gonna become of ryan
he's gonna be fine all right let's chitty chatty
before we do a word from today's video sponsor
thank you to storyblocks for sponsoring this video
being the cinematic artisans we obviously are we
are always in search of ways to make our videos
look better faster and most of all for cheap
cheap is good and if you're a content creator or
filmmaker or anything in between you're probably
in a similar position it's tough to get your
content looking as good as it can be without
breaking the bank or burning yourself out in
the process which is why i heavily encourage you
guys to check out what storyblocks has to offer
cheap is good do you feel like this is their way
of telling us that the videos could be looking
better yes whether it's the credibility of an
exotic establishing shot the soothing comfort
of the perfect music bed or just the satisfaction
of increasing your graphical capability storybox
has an incredibly inclusive and diverse library of
faces places sounds titles transitions filters and
effects and more over a million assets royalty
free and available for personal and commercial
use with your membership sounds so affordable this
is this is quite affordable they have multiple
subscription levels to suit your exact needs
whether you're an independent indie solo creator
or a whole team so if you want to learn more head
on down to our link in the description box and get
started that's at storyblocks.com rejects now back
to the video all right i'm gonna kick us off with
first thing to talk about john oh jesus uh i mean
what an ending to the the freaking season i mean
the way that they have managed like it's i think
it's hard it takes probably a lot of ingenuity
in the writers room to figure out how to keep a
character like homelander ever escalating and ever
sort of developing and warping in the levels
of depravity and just what a threat he is
to not only people physically but
also just as an ideological symbol and
to watch to watch the back and forth with ryan
in this episode was like especially sort of heart
crunching because they've already done things
surrounding you know radicalization and and uh
how people who are a bit older and who have a
little more life experience get indoctrinated
into these things but you know for for him as you
know still very much a child in a lot of ways and
having these really conflicting experiences with
different guardians and father figures like it
it's such a kind of heart-rending end in that
sense like ugh like the soul of ryan like i have
to imagine that in the next season that's going
to be a heavy theme because i mean you know you
see it at the end there he's not that vexed that
his dad just blew some nude's head up so yeah
like yeah i feel like especially building
up soldier boy and like this you know
homelander scale threat dealing with all that like
this definitely feels like at least for soldier
boy sort of an interstitial piece like there can
definitely be more with him but just as the arc of
again homelander i feel like you come in
every season be like man where are they gonna
are they gonna keep him feeling like this volatile
you know horrific presence and i think they
they manage it here and and especially with
these emotional curveballs that they throw
there were a lot of points especially
towards the end when like the three of
them are all in the same room together
grandfather son and grandson like
the the amount of emotional suspense along
with the physical stakes i thought that was
really great yeah this whole season seemed to be
about literally the inheriting the sins of your
father and how that's passed along and uh how
we all react as as we go about our lives like a
lot of father and son themes was pretty much the
through line for everyone of whatever inherited
trauma there was even write down like mother's
milk inheriting uh the the life experiences he's
had soldier boy you get to hear his backstory of
how he was treated and then he quickly morphs into
adopting his father's point of view
while interacting with homelander
and homelander you know i just think anthony
stars performance when he is interacting with
soldier boy just like how he starts breaking
down in front of him i really really love anthony
stark's performance because he can has a such a
range of just knowing each and every moment of
what this character is thinking and feeling and
then to have a scene where you're on the you're
on the brink of something very explosive and
and then to have him literally succumb to tears
in front of ryan and begging to be a family in
that moment and that's kind of a through line for
all these characters as we've seen with butcher
from season two to especially this season with
exploring his past so i think like thematically
they all kept it on board for how they kept it on
board for exactly how each one of these people
would ultimately respond to situations and
it does leave it in a fascinating spot for every
one of them like look i know people don't like to
hear this but homelanders trump all right that's
not my opinion it's pretty obvious what they're
doing and for all you trump supporters out there
that's what they're they're doing today yeah it's
something that i've talked with other people who
do like videos on the boys and they actually try
to refrain from saying that they they they try to
keep it out because there's definitely going to be
redemption arc like i don't want to stir this up
turn out good i don't want to stir something up in
the comments i don't want to and it's like it's so
obvious it's what they're doing and they just know
you know who the filmmakers are involved in
creating this piece yeah you know it's what
they're commenting on so whether you like it or
not that's what they're doing and especially in
those final moments you know uh what the crowd
is representing and the fact he could do such a
violent act and the crowd will just cheer him
on be like yay we uplift you we support you
you're doing the thing the mainstream wouldn't
do you're going against it all uh and it's it
is that's the kind of commentary i i tend to like
no we haven't seen trump murder a guy in front of
a crowd of people we haven't uh but it's it's so
obvious it's what what they're doing and you'd be
naive to think that's not that's not what
they're commenting um so that is it leaves
it in a more disgusting morbid place um for
where homelander can play around it because now
he's at a spot where he just killed in his last
season you know a big part when victoria newman
was going up against homelander in the public was
there was a video capturing homelander murdering
um you know an innocent died and you see him just
killing like terrorists and then uh he was trying
to defend himself but everyone was against him and
now here he murders someone right in front of a
crowd of people in the states and everyone cheers
him on and so that gives him even more free reign
to now be more sadistic and and indulge in his
more violent senses more than ever when he's got
the support of the people to allow him to do so
the people who have motivated him validated him
and now he can keep on going down this path and
to you know this tug of war that they'd have with
ryan i like the fliparoo of where last season ends
with ryan choosing to go with butcher and this
season ends with butcher and all them being saved
because ryan's the one who's pulling homeland away
and choosing to go with homelander i think it is
a good fliparoo and it creates a more interesting
conflict of for for someone like butcher and
what a genius way to to have the tables turn
in the heat of a moment uh in your finale of
butcher will not let ryan die yeah he can and
if he let ryan die could have killed homeland or
they would have been in this situation um but i
think that is just clever clever writing because
ryan's kind of been in the background a little bit
one could see i think you know one k i would have
liked to have checked in with ryan a tad a bit
more to be totally honest there was a part of me
that's like i could have used a little bit more of
i don't know what ellie would have done
better than that he's chilling on the farm
like bored as hell he's just chilling and stewing
about that last moment with butcher yeah bonnie
with mallory you know um yeah there's not much
more you could have done granted but who knows
maybe just developing the relationship with that
mallory and and this to make that kind of that
heart-wrenching pull a little bit more um however
i do think that's really clever to have it turn
because you you keep wondering like is it going to
be soldier boy who ultimately succumbs to being a
father and and embracing his his son now is that
who it's going to be and i like the difference
that the the the divide that that is established
of what he's like calling homeland or a [__]
and saying you know like you just seek this love
and stuff like he he views him as weak and so
showing that he's not like him that they are too
they are two different people and in response to
how they wish to be perceived i think that's
really great at drawing the line there and
does make it if you feel like you're setting
up for something even more chaotic i do like
that they kept them alive i do like that
because it there's more doors to explore
with soldier boy and you know like they keep
the way they shift the dynamics of team-ups
and enemies it's so so invigorating the way they
they do it because they don't rely on like nuke
like there's always a new cast member every
season there's always some new players
but this show is not heavily reliant on that
it's really just about how do you mix things
up it's not that the key to the stakes is oh
we gotta have a new character to to you know
get you afraid that they will die or something
yeah it's they're good at playing the chess game
and shifting around people's allegiances
and and making you wonder because they're
you know like a train is like a perfect example of
that it's like how many experiences will it take
for this guy to finally maybe land on the right
side of anything and it doesn't seem like at this
point it will ever happen but they're really
good at at least convincing you that it maybe
could someday and that makes for really fun
both you know drama and you know the lighter mo
i feel like the deep is like the more light
version of that where you're like this guy's
never gonna change this guy is gonna always be
who he is uh and yet i don't know they still find
interesting things to make out of that and they
still kind of hold the statuses and the dynamics
well and and you know like losing noir this
episode like that felt pretty momentous still
uh because you know we see how powerless everybody
is and to a degree they've always been so but uh
yeah to kind of get to the end it's like you have
homelander at the top of everything and we had
noir and they they do nicely it's like they've
given him this personality and then they've
embellished it you know they started with the body
language and they embellished it here with the
the cartoon animals but even beyond that i just
liked the triangle that they drew like there was
a certain closeness and admiration between black
noir and soldier boy until that relationship turns
you know horribly sour just because of who soldier
boy is and then you know the way that mutates into
his relationship to homelander like that like as
much as in a way it's not one of the main main
main characters dying and maeve doesn't actually
die i still was like wow you know for for black
noir to go out like this does feel pretty harsh
and does feel pretty momentous in this moment
and he is the one member of the team you might
actually mourn for if they died yeah it's like
no one on the seven necessarily was a good person
even black noir was not necessarily a good person
um but he was the one you were most sympathetic
towards because the show always did things to
demonstrate his sensitivity whether it be in
season one where he plays the piano or when he's
learning about compound b and he's he's crying
in the hallway in season two and then here they
really capitalize on that even more but showing
how he was treated by soldier boyd with payback
and who he feels he can interact with others like
cartoon looney tunes and animal-like friends of
his you know they really showed um just who he
really is at his at his core that even despite
he is his violent individual that he really
is uh this thing of sensitivity and there's
like there's frightened yeah there's like there's
still a child in there yeah he's automatically
endearing no matter how horrible you make the
character to some extent was something about
the way when he showed up i was like i smell death
on this guy yeah he's gonna die and uh the second
you know he admitted fault uh or admitted to have
having kept that as hidden from homelanders up
dude's dead right away because that's the thing
he holds that's the homelander values most
you know and it's like the more homelander
what they've been doing with homelanders the
more they strip away every element of facade or
something that he would latch onto to feel worthy
or to feel the sense of belonging the more they
do that the more they strip those qualities away
the more he starts to like come out of his shell
the more the the thing that will lead to the
scorching of the earth as they put it and i love
that i love that quality so gonna miss black noir
really was a delightful presence i feel like
in some way he could survive that still but not
part of me was wondering if they were going
to have it be that on that like you know darth
vader on a table you know getting stitched up and
and you know either some kind of mumbo jumbo with
compound v or something with you know mechanical
parts blah blah blah but i don't know i i honestly
feel like it could still happen but part of me
is is as much as i am bummed to see a character
go it does make things feel real and finite
so yeah i was sitting there bargaining myself
watching his little intestines spray blood and
i'm like but he could come back from this somehow
right but well on the right now it doesn't feel
like it on the flip with maeve i think i think
her character deserved to live i hope that her
character does not i hope that if like i don't
know what the season plans are for season four
like is that supposed to be the final one i know
they announced that early on with this debut
of this season but they might have the season
four and five i imagine they can go on for a while
there's many stories to draw from with the comics
but where they end off with maeve here i think is
very strong because she's had such a defined arc
um especially from season one to now you know and
i appreciate that they brought it back around from
this season of her training with the fighting and
then you know she's being held prisoner so you
don't really think anything's going to happen with
it you don't really think she i didn't actually
think she'd be like having a fight with homeland
or be able to hold her own throughout most of it
but i thought it was a very worthy fight like her
the brutality and the ferociousness of her like
just how she wouldn't stop going no matter what
was happening to her no matter how injured she got
and obviously homelander was just like holding
back but he was still getting dealt some pretty
you know pretty awful blows throughout and then
for her to have like the ultimate sacrifice in
the in the image of everyone i'm surprised
she live anyway if anything i'm like i'm
surprised you survived that like you were
like up close with him at that moment and
the explosion happened happening you fell to the
ground like i i would think you would die um but
i think you know just in terms of like audience
members association with the character who was
kind of like frustrating to me in the beginning of
season two who then i really started to root for
and then this whole time you know who's just kind
of been put through the ringer and beaten and
put down and all ways to then have this moment i
thought was really rewarding and i thought that
uh they earned it i think that's the
most important thing is they earned
what she ultimately got to have in the end i think
everyone did essentially like i like who french
he's evolved into someone more confident and sure
of himself and is like gonna finally be able to
stand up to butcher um hughie was more so coming
at realizations of what real strength is versus
the physicality side of it no eric you kind of
pissed off some people the other day on twitter
with howie defined because someone asked him a
question about why is it okay why would starla
i think it's okay for um kimiko to get powers
through compound v again but wasn't okay for
huey and he answered something along the lines of
i have to remember him totally paraphrasing here
but something along the lines of like huey
was doing it because he wanted to feel macho
whereas kimiko was doing it because it comes from
like a sense of wanting to protect you know and
and whatnot and take ownership of something
that you've been so uh you know torn up over
and and felt it was thrust upon you unfairly
yeah crippy didn't say that um humphrey did
cripty didn't say that it was a very specific
tweet that he put out and it was pissing off
a lot of people because i'm like oh so
man can't take it to defend his woman but
there's a whole bunch of context that
i'm sure he could have put in a tweet
that's not the point and also you know v24
doesn't have the same effect does come movie
so i i do like uh i do like what huey
ultimately learned especially that
learning lesson he does have about his father
because he he seemed to kind of reject and
judge everything about his father never
understood him and it seemed like he
finally understood who his father was and
what strength his father actually possessed
the even though the show would even kind of
paint him as someone who was weak that there
was actually not a lot of weakness in what he
did but a lot of strength in what he did and i
i like that that whenever they go more gray i'm
really happy about that and them getting to tell
his daughter the truth about the past sounds like
they don't know that soldier boy's still alive
um but can't do that butcher being set up now for
he's got a timeline of when he might when he would
die i hope the show goes through with him actually
dying i like when they commit to that [__] he's
got a specific timeline here and now he has to
uh now they have to adhere to that they're saying
he's got like 12 months to live shouldn't they
back home with some [__] but every season from
now on is only four days i mean this the time
to take place and tend to be relatively short
yeah tend to be like a few weeks you can still
squeeze a good amount of stories yeah those last
18 months on the long end yeah i i think this
is my favorite season um i'm not entirely sure
i don't like immediately jumping on the bandwagon
of that uh but i i think this is my favorite one
i really i think it could easily be mine as well
i mean i think the way that this season has both
encapsulated you know the the growth of their
combinations of the iconography and imagery of
superheroes and all that stuff with the satire and
the commentary i feel like they've had a pretty
you know just solid grip on you know each season
they get a little more assured about that and then
this season in particular um it's like yeah
having every episode feel like a standalone
kind of installment and also having it be that
uh you have so many of the core ensemble like
it didn't feel like they felt forced to have
everyone together or to you know recreate all
the same dynamics as before like there's a lot
of uh disparity between the boys between a lot
of different people there's a lot of pairings off
and whatnot and i thought that made for yeah nice
character explorations nice confrontations and
nice moments where we have no idea what's going to
happen we feel jeopardy for you know our core team
who i guess you could argue probably not going to
die but at least i know we sat here every week
going oh god please don't kill french or kimiko
or even mother's milk like i i yeah i i liked
the ultimate growth and resolution yeah frenchie
stands up mm gets to sort of legitimize uh you
know his trauma with his daughter instead of
you know trying to create this perfect world
uh yeah and everybody like nobody felt useless
or anything like that or like they were spinning
their wheels to get you know somebody involved
like not every character is the most integral to
every episode but yeah this felt well proportioned
and well just conceived in terms of where everyone
is and what everyone's going through it feels like
there's more to come but also like they made
a crisp package out of this particular season
i think starlight what's her name roddy catherine
catherine moriarty catherine moriarty i think
that's her name forgive me if i'm wrong on
that uh her last name is moriarty she's an
incredible actress and i feel like she's not
talked about it enough yeah you kind of just
accept her kind of the way you accept like carl
urban yeah you just accept her but she is she is
the the way they've developed her character and
flushed her out as this as this you know brave
individual and someone with a sense of like true
strength possessed coming first internally then
externally i think is so awesome of her and she's
one of the people i moral ground wise and then
physical wise when she's around i feel like a
sense of safety and security when she's there
and uh as a leader as well how she's really
morphed into that you know like the first
season really felt like her huey a butcher and
homelander were the main characters and they've
they've kind of kept that through line with
her especially and i think she's such a i don't
feel like she gets enough recognition for her
contribution to this show she's phenomenal and she
maintained being phenomenal to me from the
beginning of the season to the very end
and the range she displays so great and
i was really worried that soldier boy was
going to kill her yeah i thought soldier
was going to get the jump on her um yeah
excellent work there hey train i don't know what
to feel about him i mean i i i feel like the
uh the episode could tug and pull with the
audience but i like the way they decide to explore
that and especially with the whole the brother
being being like you shouldn't have killed him we
needed justice to be served and we wanted to see
him locked up basically you want to see him suffer
and be punished and see the image taken down for
the public to see exactly i see this guy's mug
shot know that he is not a good guy and that's
the retribution that the community needed to
yeah and so because now he's gonna get that
heroes send off blah blah blah yeah yeah um
and ashley you know like i i like
the way they paint her because
you know she's she's always i i you i always feel
how torn she is even when she seems dead set on a
particular path but so much of what like she
has to pretty much hide or deny moral values
in order to survive you know like she she's always
caught in fear and has to constantly act off of
that and i thought the physical representation
of just how much this tears at her you know
literally yeah of you know she pulled out all of
her hair and it just looks so painful that she has
to wear a wig like she that's how that's how she
lets out everything she's feeling internally and
i thought that was a really fascinating character
reveal on her end well in a way they've co-opted
it into like a kink coping mechanism too like
again like the way they flesh and develop even
characters like that is like so twisted and
fascinating and she does a terrific job too
and i think uh you know that they lay some type
of groundwork i thought was really clever and and
of you know ashley number two she doesn't let go
on the helipad and you see that look that ashley
number two has it's like she's she's gonna
remember that and then ashley two's with her
when she deletes the footage of maeve and some
i'm like uh you can't trust anyone in the show
you could use that against her she could totally
use that against her in some way if that means
her climbing the ranks yeah everyone tries to
do a vaught climb the ladder yeah even if there
was an off-screen kumbaya how long could that
last when opportunity and leverage are applied
yeah i'm sad the seasons wrapped up
but it was an amazing journey another
knockout season for the boys rush yeah um not sure
why i'd rank it yet but probably my favorite now
all right guys what did you think about
this season leave your thoughts down below
you can subscribe click that notification
bell leave a like thank you to storyblocks
for sponsoring this video check us out on
our podcast and whatnot if you're already
here at the podcast thanks for being here
uh anyway let's do this for the patreon
aniso oliva anisa i've took me eight episodes to
finally get here but i'm wearing the supernatural
shirt you got it actually i think you got us two
but but this is the my favorite one i often get
compliments on it whenever i go out in public or
go to the gym or even in it people are always like
bitching shirts what they always say so nisa
thank you for uh helping me out with my attire
for today getting a chance to represent it and
i want to thank you for being you you've been
an amazing friend to us on all accounts and an
amazing listener and you just have this like
kind of unconditional support and love that
is really hard to find so thank you for being
with us for so long and you know you're you're
you're above average to us broke the bell curve
yeah you're a really special lady to us so you're
super i can't wait to hang out with you again when
you're out here in california or when the day
inevitably comes when we finally visit texas but
thank you for being you and know that you have
our hearts with you forever much love dear